on has been a valued police officer for
26 years committed to Public Service as
a senior investigating officer
supporting victims and their families in
bringing offenders to Justice
John is held in the highest esteem
within our organization
he is a credit to his family and to the
Police Service
and of course our thoughts are with John
and his family as he fights for his life
in hospital today
I would like to take this opportunity to
thank the members of the public and the
Emergency Services who worked so hard
last night to save John's life
John's colleagues are understandably
extremely distressed by last night's
shooting
however they remain Resolute and
committed to bringing those responsible
for this heinous crime to Justice
I also welcome the cross-party political
condemnation of last night's attack
however it is tragic and sad that there
are still some who wish to drag us back
to the past
I've also received numerous messages of
support from colleagues partners and
politicians as well as the public were
all United in their support for policing
I and my colleagues are grateful for
their strength of the condemnation of
this awful attack
so before ACC McEwen and myself take
questions I would also like to confirm
that in this fast-paced investigation
this morning we have arrested three men
age 38 45 and 47 in Oma and coal Island
in connection with John's attempted
murder they're currently been questioned
by detectives at mosgrave serious crime
Suite thank you
the organization
so
the investigation is at an early stage
we're keeping an open mind at the moment
our primary focus of that investigation
is your own violent dissonance
Republicans
and within that a group called new IRA
we continue to work against these groups
we know that they have a level of
capability and as we've seen this
horrific attack play out last night as I
say we're keeping an open mind that's
where the focus of the investigation is
at this moment and you will understand
why I will be drawn in further details
this time
I'm gonna ask you
foreign
did a talk last night we saw that John
was finishing up from coaching and under
15's football team
he was accompanied by his young son and
in fact putting footballs into the boot
of his car uh when two gunmen appeared
fired multiple shots John ran a short
distance and as he fell to the ground
the gunman continued to fire shots at
him
um as we said earlier in the game we'd
like to acknowledge uh the the
assistance and the quick Brave actions
of one member of the public who gave
First Aid on the actions of our partners
in the ambulance service
at this time there were many other young
people children awaiting pick up by
their parents news children ran for
cover in share Tire towards the center
um
in terms of the
the ongoing uh threat assessment that
you mentioned
um that is we we work against a threat
level of substantial which means that an
attack is likely we continue to review
that and as the investigation works on
we continue to work against these groups
so John was a senior uh officer a senior
investigating officer he had a high
profile
all our officers work against the
backdrop of a substantial threat and as
the chief says we will do everything we
can to support them
um and and we continue to work in that
environment and our officers continue to
review their own security again I would
like to appeal to the public with any
information around either the gunman the
vehicle or anything no matter how small
that they think might help this inquiry
to come forward please
is it is all officer
yeah thank you I think absolutely this
has sent a huge shock wave across the
organization we've been speaking
principally with the police Federation
but also with those representatives of
senior officers and police staff who
would see themselves under threat
clearly one of the things it defines us
is our resilience on our commitment to
keep going in dark times and tough times
so John knows that his colleagues will
now be working tirelessly Round the
Clock to support his recovery but also
to bring the offenders that have tried
to kill him to Swift Justice
thank you
so as I say we're keeping an open mind
in terms of the investigation but the
primary focus of that investigation at
this time is violent dissident
Republicans on the new Ira within that
you'll understand why I'll Reserve any
further comment at this time in terms of
resources clearly it's a it's a question
that's bound to come up at this
difficult time uh myself and Mark are
confident we have sufficient resource to
pursue the offenders that have committed
this crime but clearly in days ahead
they may well require the questions asks
about the prospects of losing 800 police
officers whilst trying to fight against
an uptake in Terrorist activity
so in terms of the isolated incident as
I say
I go back to the point we work against a
backdrop of a substantial threat which
means an attack is likely our officers
and staff every day working against that
context we continue to work against uh
violentest and Republicans and other
groups who seek to harm our community
and seek to attack officers in this
horrific way with a callous disregard
for our community we will continue to do
that
and in terms of how away I mean
certainly as a chief Constable it's the
one phone call you you never want to get
that you've had a colleague attacked
killed or seriously injured so clearly
it's a deeply troubling day for the
organization that suffered so much in
the past and clearly we want to send a
message of support and thanks to
officers and staff who continue to fight
terrorism organized crime and protect
our communities but also to the
community themselves who are blanket
around us to keep us safe
so again you'll understand why I would
Reserve any detail like others this is
the early stages of the investigation
and we're keeping an open minded Etc
thank you